Massachusetts lottery officials revealed
minutes ago that they initially gave the
wrong location for where the winning
Powerball ticket was sold just one
ticket matched the number 6 7 16 23 26
and the Powerball number 4 now that
jackpot is worth seven hundred and fifty
eight point seven million dollars thank
you very much officials now say the
ticket was sold in Chicopee
Massachusetts that's near Springfield
not at the Handy variety store in
Watertown Massachusetts this first
thought were all the media's gathered
Jericka Duncan is in Watertown outside
that store that initially thought it had
the big winner Jericka good morning
they're gone womp womp this morning
hello yeah good morning you can imagine
the news spreading very quickly people
who live here feel like what we are not
the winners all of the media around here
going what lottery officials got it
wrong but that is the case it still
doesn't change the basic information
though that this ticket was the biggest
jackpot for a single winner the payout
for that 1.6 billion back in January of
26 well that had to be split among three
people so that's why this one is very
significant when you think about one
person or one ticket winning all of this
money now Massachusetts lottery winners
cannot stay anonymous but they can claim
their winnings through a trust the
winner has one year to claim the prize
and the store that sold that lucky
ticket again in Chicopee Massachusetts
will get fifty thousand dollars now
while the jackpot was nearly seven
hundred fifty nine million dollars most
winners take the lump sum option which
would pay out about 480 million before
taxes and that amount would be taxed
about 40 percent now let's just have a
little fun with this this is patriots
country nor this is for you the
Superbowl champions keep that in mind if
the winner were to take that 480 million
dollar lump sum even after taxes they
would be able to purchase every single
ticket to the next Super Bowl all right
which we all know will involve the
Patriots right
yeah we'll see how Jericka says we'll
see about that but it's in Chicopee the
real store is pride Station in store and
they didn't even know that they had one
until CBS this morning called them and
said hey guess what you're the winners
can you imagine number one I hope it's a
group of people that won yeah except if
you're the one person that's holding the
ticket you're saying Gail stop talking
it gets to split all that money and how
did you sleep last night if you're
holding a winning obviously pie you know
I've heard lawyers say if you if you
have the discipline don't come forward
for many months so you can get your
affairs in order you know you are
celebrate and it's like a hot ticket
absolutely and finding relatives you
didn't know you had that's a new friend
thanks to Jericka for that report